so we're starting to see sort of a new
divide in the fight against coronavirus
earlier you had these metro areas with
larger population densities more flights
directly to China you started seeing
those areas have more cases pretty early
so New York City certainly at the top of
that list Boston would be another
example as well
and you've got places that are less
connected to the global economy having
fewer cases early on we are now starting
to see divergence where the numbers are
starting to improve
pretty dramatically in some of these
early hotspots in terms of a reduction
in cases and a reduction in deaths and
reduction in serious cases in people in
icy use but we have a new wave of cases
in places that have been insisting all
along hey I don't know that we need to
close we don't have any cases and very
quickly they are getting many many more
cases and they still seem to not
understand how viral growth works now
let's look at one example and that's
Mississippi Republican governor Tate
Reeves was insisting for weeks
Mississippi can open we can open
Mississippi everything's great here and
indeed he decided to go ahead and open
businesses the cases spiked and he is
cancelling that plan he's calling it a
pause but okay I mean eventually
businesses will open the plan to open
now has been cancelled Friday
Mississippi at about 400 new cases and
20 new deaths and they have changed
their plans governor Kate Reeves should
actually be applauded for doing this we
shouldn't make fun of the fact that his
initial plan was wrong he should be
praised because he's actually looking at
the data and changing the plan because
when you look at other places that have
started to open and it's still in some
cases we don't even see the full effect
yet places like Florida are quickly
finding more and more new cases despite
still having pretty low levels of
testing Virginia is now finding close to
a thousand new cases a day Texas is
finding close to a thousand new cases a
day and they're only testing a third or
a quarter of what places like
Massachusetts and Rhode Island and New
York are testing if you're only testing
14,000 people a day and you're finding a
thousand new cases a day those numbers
are going to go up even fast
as you start to test more Indiana is
another place that supposedly had no
problem they were all set to go one of
the top growth rates by percentage now
over the weekend Ohio becoming a hotspot
Georgia may be the hot spot by the end
of the week as governor Kemp there has
just blown the doors wide open Georgia
has nearly 30,000 cases now I believe
that if we had stayed as close to fully
shut down as possible just two more
weeks everywhere we would have been in a
good position to have more testing by
then and to be able to start easing
restrictions and guidelines but now a
lot of these states are going to fall
very very far back here in Massachusetts
Republican governor Charlie Baker
extended the stay at home order it was
supposed to end today may for Charlene
Baker has extended it by two weeks to
May 18th and we've seen cases level off
we've got about a 3% new case rate per
day and it hasn't been climbing we've
seen a net decrease in hospitalizations
over the last week deaths have dropped
from close to 200 a day to about 100 a
day still a lot still tragic but that's
the direction you want to see things
going my instinct is that in another 14
days if Massachusetts keeps doing this
the numbers are going to look
dramatically better the opposite seems
to be happening in many southern states
now I want to praise Mississippi they
had a plan we thought it was the wrong
plan many of us did they looked at the
data and they changed the plan we can
focus on it was a bad plan to start with
and it was a bad plan to start with but
lots of states have bad plans and many
of them aren't changing the plans as the
data changes Georgia Texas and Florida
are examples at least governor Tate
Reeves realized the plan doesn't match
the data and we have to change our plan
Mississippi is a place with the worst
health care in the country according to
u.s. News 50th out of 50 they can't risk
having their system overwhelmed which
would lead to a very high death rate he
changed his mind and that's great let's
see what happens in these other places
cases spike Texas and Georgia we will be
following closely all week many states
now also have armed protesters demanding
that they be reopened
protesters showing up yelling at cops
typically not wearing face masks very
very ugly stuff if you love feeding your
intellectual curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time favorite apps called
blink it's blink Isleta consume an
entire book on your way home from work
they take thousands of popular
non-fiction books condense each one into
text or audio that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important core ideas and information
from that book it's perfect if you don't
have enough time to do all the reading
you want to do or if you just want to
sample a book before you buy the entire
thing I recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great Stephen
Hawking this is a book that I have been
aware of for so long and other things
got in the way and it was fantastic to
check it out on blinka stinkiest has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different nonfiction
categories and a subscription is only
about eight bucks a month and you get
the entire library but you can try it
totally free and get 25% off a
subscription when you go to blink accom
slash Pakman I've put the link right
underneath this video